[Music]
we save lives every day
strangers and there's always
enough time
but i failed to save jason from this
life
joker got a hold of stolen uranium he's
selling it to terrorists
he's going to take batman and robin
together to close this case you take
them down while i investigate that
warehouse we track joker to
please tell the big man i said hello
uh
i alone will become more than the dreams
and nightmares they imagined for me
the red hood's knowledge of my tactics
my history
this was getting personal
joker showed me the truth evil can't be
cured
only killed
[Music]
life or death
because of my choice i had to avoid
repeating mistakes welcome back everyone
it's charlie this is going to be my new
batman trailer video for a death in the
family
everybody press f to pay your respects
in the chat for jason todd
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs
i'll explain what's going on with this
because they're calling it a
quote-unquote interactive movie which
some of you may recognize as a huge
easter egg in and of itself
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we'll
do a new amazon giveaway too
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what your
favorite red hood
moment is on the video so if you're not
sure what's going on here this is
obviously meant to be a prequel movie to
batman under the red hood there's a lot
of footage in there jumping around in
the timeline so it sounds like a lot of
the death in the family story will be
told in flashbacks
they also did that during the under the
red hood movie so that is why the art
style of this new movie
seems exactly the same as the batman
under the red hood movie from so many
years ago
and the reason why they're releasing
this trailer right now is because it's
the week of the anniversary of the under
the red hood movie
is also comic con week they're known to
release a couple trailers during comic
con week
but some of you may remember that jensen
ackles did the voice of jason todd
red hood during the under the red hood
movie he even dressed up like red hood
in real life recently for halloween i'm
cleaning up gotham
more than you ever did you're becoming a
crime lord yes
you can't stop crime that's what you
never understood
i'm controlling it you want to rule them
by fear
but what do you do with the ones who
aren't afraid i know everyone's waiting
for a live-action version of that
character
they have a version of jason todd on
titans so we can always hope that
they'll do an under the red hood style
story
but it's basically a choose your own
adventure style movie with alternate
endings depending on the choices that
you make in the narrative
which in and of itself is a big easter
egg call back to the original fate of
jason todd in the comic book version of
batman death in the family
some of you actually may be old enough
to have participated in that when it
actually happened way back in the day
but dc did a big write-in campaign
contest allowing readers to vote on what
would happen to jason todd would he live
or would he die at the hands of the
joker at the time dc editorial had felt
like the jason todd character just
wasn't as
popular with readers and they wanted to
go in a different direction but they
were giving the fans the readers an
opportunity to keep jason todd around
it's been so many years you probably saw
what happened as a result of that
contest
r.i.p jason todd everybody voted to kill
him off and it was
hardcore at the time they did not pull
any punches joker not only killed jason
todd
he tortured him for a good long while
before the bomb went off
but it was meant to be an impossible
scenario a no-win situation
impossible choice for batman and his
failure to save jason todd was supposed
to break him for a while
that's why this comic book panel this
page is so iconic
then a little while later they
introduced the tim drake version of
robin
obviously in the present day of this
movie it seems like jason todd is
already in the process of becoming red
hood he's already been brought back to
life by rachael ghoul
so tim drake has already graduated from
being robin to becoming red robin as an
adult
but if you didn't see the original under
the red hood movie they told a lot of
the death in the family story during
flashbacks at the beginning of the movie
and then later to explain where he came
from how red hood was born
they made a couple changes to the comic
book story and a lot of this gets into
batman hush which they just did a movie
for so it is kind of a coincidence that
they do a lot of red hood stuff right
after they do batman hush
but basic explainer is is that jason
todd dies during a death in the family
they put him in the ground they have
this eulogy
batman grieves for him eventually he
goes on to take tim drake on as the next
robin
what happened later then during the
events of batman hush is that clayface
impersonates jason todd just to freak
batman out
when they go to investigate jason todd's
grave though they find that it's empty
the body is gone
so it just leaves this big hanging
question in the air as to what happened
later as they detailed during the under
the red hood movie racial ghoul
took his body then threw him in a
lazarus pit resurrected him but he came
back
crazy because he'd been dead for so long
then he goes on to become the most
hardcore version of what he feels like
batman is not doing in gotham city like
the batman that he feels like gotham
needs not the batman that it has
all i've ever wanted to do is kill him a
day doesn't go by when i don't think
about subjecting him
to every horrendous torture he's dealt
out to others and then end him
if i allow myself to go down into that
place
i'll never come back they've done a
bunch of jason todd comic books he was a
major character during the arkham series
as the arkham knight
basically still under the red hood style
story but just doing it through the lens
of the arkham games
i don't think that jensen ackles is
voicing red hood during this movie but i
think that's just because he's gotten
too expensive they do cycle the voice
cast every once in a while
it'll be a home video released later
this year they haven't revealed the
exact release date but they're doing it
through their dc
showcase brand which is actually where
they release a lot of their short movies
a really good example of that was the
old superman shazam versus black adam
movie from a couple years ago they
released that with another short movie
on a dvd
together obviously the rock is playing
the live action dceu black atom
i've already done a couple videos for
that movie they'll be introducing the
dceu version of the justice society
during it
and during the shazam sequels they'll
finally do shazam versus black adam and
live action the rock will just pound the
crap out of the shazamly
then shazam will also go on to the next
version of the justice league movie
because of all the justice league snyder
cut stuff that's been going on lately
there's been a lot of rumors about them
doing a new justice league rebirth style
movie with a slightly different version
of the team cycling some of the roster
that doesn't include ben affleck's
batman but instead michael keaton's
batman from the multiverse
even if that winds up being true it
still wouldn't happen for at least
three to five more years minimum there's
still a bunch of other movies they have
planned before that
there was some talk about robert
pattinson's new batman joining a future
justice league after they first
announced his character like wait a
minute is he going to be the new batman
of justice league
but based on what matt reeves has said
he intends on his new batman movies to
stand apart from what you would consider
the connected
dceu movies with superman wonder woman
aquaman the flash
now shazam and black adam so the batman
2021 movie
next year will be doing its own separate
thing separate continuity
the story of that movie is largely
inspired by batman the long halloween
amazing comic book story and because
we're talking about dc
animated batman movies they're also
supposedly doing a batman the long
halloween
animated movie that's a little closer to
the comic book story next year too
there's no release date for that yet but
i think it's just funny that they're
doing
so many batman movies and so many
different versions of batman right now
so you have ben affleck's batman that's
coming back for the justice league
snyder cut next year
you have robert pattinson's batman in
the batman 2021 movie
now we have a new batman red hood movie
and then we have michael keaton's batman
coming back during the flash
flashpoint movie and other future dc
movies and if you don't watch the titans
tv show there's also a tv version of
batman on that too but he's played by
ian glenn from game of thrones sergiora
batman so he's a little bit older
version of the character
it is a really good time to be a batman
fan there's so many batman flying around
the next three to four years the whole
deal with the flash flashpoint movie
michael keaton batman is that he's going
to be from the tim burton movies it'll
be his version
coming back but an older version so
we're all hoping for a live action
batman beyond movie
they did say that they're trying to lock
him down for a multi-movie contract so
it does sound like they're trying to
build up to actually doing a legit
live-action batman beyond movie which i
think would be everyone's dream
dc fandom is happening in august they're
going to be doing
panels for all the big upcoming dc
movies and dropping trailers so i'll do
videos for everything i'm not expecting
a big trailer for the batman movie but
there will be a new justice league
snyder cut trailer in a couple other
trailers for the other dc stuff
zack snyder just released a brand new
justice league snyder cut trailer this
past week at comic con you can click
here for that trailer
and click here for all my other big
comic con trailer videos
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you